- Please welcome Fortune Feimster.
(laughing)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Yes!
Have a seat.
- Okay thank you.
- Hi!
- [Fortune] Oh my gosh.
- You're so funny.
- [Fortune] Thank you.
- Oh my god I love you.
Meet Norman Leary.
- How are you?
- Oh I'm stoked.
- Ow.
(laughing)
- I'm so strong.
- He was cracking up,
we're both cracking up
watching you in your
Hooters spiel, I love it.
- I'm between two legends right now.
- No, not the same.
(audience cheering)
Not the same at all.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
What a treat.
- I'll take it but totally a lie.
Your accent reminds me of home,
I always love when I run into you.
Like it just feels...
So where did you grow up?
- I grew up in North Carolina.
My mom made me be a debutante,
that's how southern I am.
- [Kelly] You're a southern belle.
- I am.
- You're a southern belle.
Wait, what did that entail?
What did you have to do?
Oh my gosh!
- I was like, what happened?!
(audience laughing)
- You are so fancy right now.
- [Fortune] Yeah I had to
wear a white wedding gown.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, you
were from the bricks.
I was from the sticks,
girl, we didn't have anything like that.
- Listen, but we had no money.
That was the thing, my mom had been one
and then we lost all our money.
(laughing)
It happens.
- It happens.
- You know, gambling and...
(laughing)
And then she still wanted me to carry on
this tradition of pretending to be rich
and then go to etiquette classes.
- That's amazing.
- [Norman] Etiquette classes?
- Yeah I had to learn how to be a lady.
(laughing)
No I didn't know, I didn't know.
- [Kelly] I don't.
- I had to like,
dab my face with a napkin.
You can't wipe your face like a monster!
(laughing)
- Obviously I didn't
attend etiquette class.
- Well still to this day,
people are like, you
should never eat in public
'cause it's not great.
- So what did your family think whenever
you told them you were gay?
'Cause being from the south
that is not always an easy conversation.
- Yeah, I mean I think my mom for her
she just, she didn't
want my life to be harder
than what life can be.
- Already.
- Already but we had this
really poignant moment,
I talk about it in my special
where I told her I was gay
and she was stone faced
and I was like oh man,
does she hate me now?
She was like, we are goin' to Hooters!
(laughing)
I was like what!
So that was her way of being,
I accept you, let's go to Hooters.
(laughing)
And then when I told my dad,
he was like, he's very
typical southern man
that's very simple and he's like, okay.
All right, well you wants us
to buy you a men's blazer?
(laughing)
Or a top hat?
Lesbians don't wear top hats.
- I love your dad.
In his mind, like if women like women
you wanna dress like a man.
- For sure.
He was like, okay let's get
you that top hat and blazer.
- That's kind of amazing though.
Being from the south
that they were accepting
'cause I know a lot, I have
a lot of friends actually,
or few friends that they
didn't say let's go to Hooters
they said let's go to church
and they wanted to pray for 'em and like
change 'em straight or something
and I'm like, I don't
think your prayers gonna
make 'em straight, just sayin'.
Yeah so it can be hard for people.
- A hundred percent, I mean
we've come a long way
but there's still plenty
of people who are
disowned by their families
and I'm so lucky that my family--
- [Kelly] Your parents, they're awesome.
- Yeah they were just like,
we love you no matter what.
You are no different
than you were yesterday.
And I mean, yeah.
- That's so good.
That's so good.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- So you talk about, speaking of Hooters.
You talk about Hooters in
your Netflix special a lot
so are they close to your heart?
Because I have an in.
- You do?
Well I don't know if you're aware
but I just won the Voice
recently with Jake Hoot.
- [Fortune] I did know that.
(audience cheering)
- Hooters is all about some Jake Hoot.
Hooters was so supportive--
- [Fortune] Really?
- Yes, I'm just saying they're yes he's.
- I have been talking about
Hooters my entire career.
(audience laughing)
- You just needed the voice.
You just needed the platform of the Voice.
- I needed the platform.
I was even a Hooters
waitress, not for real,
for comedy back in the day.
I wore the outfit and everything.
Listen, they wear pantyhose
so they are keepin' it classy.
And they--
(laughing)
- They're wearing pantyhose.
- And their wings are (kissing sound)
So good, so good and I--
- Their tig ol' bittie are out
but the pantyhose, super classy.
- I talk about them in my special
and still they're just like, huh?
And so I'm doin' whatever I can
to keep Hooter's legacy alive.
- We're gonna get
this partnership.
- [Norman] Where do we find
your special?
- My special's on Netflix right now.
- It's on Netflix?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] She's hilarious.
- I'll look for it.
- I would love for you to watch it.
- And if you like Hooters,
you might like the show.
- I know you're busy, you're creating
lots of shows and TV.
- Well we can do one together.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, please.
- I would love that.
- Can you call it Hooters?
(audience cheering)
It can be about owls, whatever.
Do you have any other plans?
Like big plans for 2020?
- Oh man, 2020.
- Are you gonna get married?
- My fiance is here in
the audience somewhere.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, I'm like where?
- She's over there.
Hi Jacks!
- She's way in the corner.
Actually furthest point from us.
- Nobody puts baby in the corner.
(audience laughing)
- Apparently they do.
So y'all are gonna get married?
- We're gonna get married hopefully
I mean that's the plan, right?
We're still getting married?
- You still love me, right?
- I think in May or June
and yeah I'm very excited.
I make vision boards every year.
I know my buddy Aaron
Sanchez was on your show.
- Yes.
- He brought his vision board.
- He did.
- I didn't want to copy him but I have
my own visions.
- Your own visions.
(laughing)
Not crazy at all.
- No.
I really am hoping in 2020,
I mean I want people to
watch my special for sure
but I'm really wanting to get,
I put on my Instagram
one of those, there's a Tom Cruise cakes,
I don't know if you guys.
- Is it like his face or?
- Everyone's like what?
So Tom Cruise, whenever
he works with somebody
or someone's done something for him
he sends him this coconut
cake from Doan's Bakery
and I went down this rabbit hole of Google
and learned everything
I could about this cake.
I was like, all I want
in life is for Tom Cruise
to send me a Tom Cruise coconut cake.
(laughing)
That's all I want.
- Well okay, Fortune, your
2020 vision board dreams
are about to come true, slightly.
Yeah 'cause I'm not that cool.
Tom Cruise isn't here
but we got you the cake.
- What?!
(audience cheering)
What?!
- Oh my gosh.
- You got the cake.
- So okay, so here's your official,
I don't want to touch it.
- It's so good.
I want Mr. Lear to have the first piece.
- Okay the first piece, the first piece.
- I'll take the first piece.
- There you go.
- Yes!
- I just served Norman Lear cake.
♪ Dreams come true, y'all ♪
- Do you need me to sing backup?
- You're making a song?
I can do- Yes!
- Okay I was just wondering.
- Hey I have a Vegas special
don't you threaten me
with a good time.
You come on out and sing anytime you want.
- I can play the triangle.
- Okay.
Wait why didn't I get myself a piece?
- Yeah get cake, girl.
- Let's see Tom Cruise
get your cake is like.
- Tom Cruise...
- We're thanking
Tom Cruise for this?
- Tom has no idea this is happening.
- [Kelly] No.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh, okay that's not all.
Y'all are all getting some cake too.
Do you want some?
(audience cheering)
- This is good.
- It's really good.
- It is good.
- Whoa, I'm gonna take one more bite.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- [Fortune] Really good.
- We don't need Tom Cruise
we can buy our own cakes.
- Are you guys done?
- I have to be done 'cause
I have to talk right now.
- Oh okay.
- But trust that will end
up in my dressing room.
(laughing)
- Yeah I'm done too.
- Me too.
All right, well you can
watch Fortune Feimster
Sweet & Salty on Netflix now
and don't miss her weekly
podcast, Sincerely Fortune.